si vous avez regardé les vidéos
précédentes vous savez maintenant quoi
faire si vous vous trouvez face à une
personne inconsciente qui respire face à
une personne consciente qui s'étouffe
mais si vous tombez sur quelqu'un
d'inconscient qui respire plus vous
faites quoi
on va voir ça tout de suite doug ross
cécilia reyes gregory house michaela
quinn père et shepherd elliot reid
quel est leur secret pour être si sexy
il sauve des vies ça vous fait une bonne
raison d' apprendre à sauver des vies
l'autre raison c'est qu apprendre à
sauver des vies ça peut sauver des vies
[Musique]
imaginez un peu vous êtes en discothèque
et tout d'un coup un mouvement de foule
et des cris affolé vienne interrompre
votre déhanché à la beyoncé au milieu du
dancefloor une personne était tendu
inconsciente
si vous n'avez pas assez d'imagination
on va faire une petite reconstitution
pour que vous voyez à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
bon ok on va plutôt faire une
reconstitution du geste qui sauve avec
notre mannequin de secourisme fétiche
d'abord assurez-vous que l'individu
n'est pas juste ivre mort ça peut
arriver dans les dancings dont sa
approchez-vous lui et donnez lui un
ordre simple messieurs vous m'entendez
ouvrez les yeux
c'est vraiment la main mettez un
pantalon je n'ai pas fait quelque chose
s'ils répondent pas vérifié sa
respiration et libéré ses voies
respiratoires comme on l'a vu dans la
vidéo sur la pls
si la victime ne respire pas ou qu'elle
respire mal elle est en arrêt cardio
respiratoire ou à va pas tarder à l'être
demander à quelqu'un de prévenir les
secours ou appeler à l'aide si vous êtes
tout seul
et puis il va falloir y aller et
commencé la réanimation si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas à commencer par placer la
victime à plat dos sur un sol dur et
retirer tout ce qu'il faudrait vous
gêner à commencer par le t-shirt la
chemise le corsage le soutien gorge et
s'est agenouillé vous à côté de sa
poitrine à califourchon sur son bras
croiser les doigts en plaçant la paume
de votre main sur le dos de l'autre et
appuyer le talon gottmar au milieu de la
poitrine à ce stade demandé au dj de
mettre staying alive des bee gees
parce que c'est une chanson qui a
exactement le même rythme que celui que
vous devez avoir pour faire le massage
cardiaque
c'est à dire à peu près cent trois
compressions par minute bon certains
médecins ont émis des réserves sur le
bien-fondé de cette technique mais
franchement cela met l'ambiance à tous
les
on se place et vous au dessus de la
victime bien à la verticale épaules bras
avant bras et mains perpendiculaire à sa
poitrine verrouillé bien les coudes et
enfoncé le thorax de 4 à 5 cm en le
laissant bien revenir à sa position
initiale quand vous relâcher la pression
ce que vous êtes en train de faire c'est
de remplacer le coeur de la victime qui
marchent plus en compensant à sa place
ça permet de maintenir une forme de
circulation sanguine et d'apporter de
l'oxygène aux organes et notamment au
cerveau tout ça pour limiter la casse en
attendant qu'un médecin arrive et tente
de faire repartir le coeur mais pour ça
je vous renvoie à la très bonne vidéo de
primum non nocere et qui explique ça
très bien
je vous mets le lien dans la description
attention voilà quelques erreurs à ne
pas commettre
[Musique]
mais non on masse avec les coudes
verrouillé on a dit pas plier
ah là il va péter les côtes là faut bien
se centrer sur la poitrine c'est
important
n'importe quoi mais qui fait ça enfin
dans les premières minutes d'un arrêt
cardiaque le massage ça peut suffire
mais si vous savez faire du bouche à
bouche vous pouvez y aller la technique
c'est une main sur le front deux ou
trois doigts sous le manteau on bascule
doucement la tête en arrière on ouvre la
bouche on pince le nez on prend une
inspiration
on couvre entièrement la bouche de la
victime avec la sienne et on s'ouvre
doucement pendant une seconde avant de
se redresser de reprendre son souffle et
de recommencer et au sucre et à la
cherche mon chewing-gum gelé perdu si
vous faites du bouche à bouche et que
vous êtes tout seul le rythme c'est
d'alterner 30 compressions et 2
insufflations et de recommencer
n'hésitez pas à demander à ce qu'on
vienne vous relayez parce que c'est
épuisant et plus on est fatigué - on est
efficace dans tous les cas vous
continuez jusqu'à ce que les secours
arrivent ou jusqu'à ce que la victime
reprennent une respiration normale
si l'arrêt cardiaque a lieu dans un
endroit disposant d'un défibrillateur
n'hésitez pas à l'utiliser en suivant
les consignes que va vous donner la
machine et surtout si vous ne retenez
pas tout ce que je vous ai dis n'ayez
pas peur de mal faire
dites vous bien que si personne ne fait
rien la victime va mourir alors vaut
mieux tenter un truc même si on n'est
pas au top
en attendant les pros ça améliore très
clairement les chances de survie de la
victime
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau geste qui sauve abonnez
vous pour pas rater ça en attendant
éviter les ennuis
prenez soin de vous prenez soin des
autres et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]